the Flash's second trailer is building
the hype and we've got a breakdown of
the good and the bad of how the fans are
reacting Ezra Miller's Barry Allen may
or may not have a future in James Gunn
and Peter safran's DCU following the
flash star string of arrests and
assorted controversies Gunn's Monumental
praise for the flash indicates that
regardless of Miller's behind the scenes
troubles the film is nothing short of a
complete and utter Delight I completely
broke the universe
The Flash is set to premiere on June
16th and thanks to cinemacon people who
aren't directly affiliated with the
studio have finally gotten a peek at the
movie if their first reactions are
anything to go by the flash has one
intriguing piece of superhero Cinema
critic and journalist Scott Menzel
tweeted this after seeing the film The
flashes hands down one of the best
superhero films of all time no joke The
Flash is the ultimate movie-going
experience as it has a little bit of
everything action emotion heart humor
and plenty of nostalgia he also prays
Stars Miller Michael Keaton and Sasha
Kaye as well as the movie's considerable
re-watch potential Menzel also made a
point of noting that the movie has
plenty of extremely spoilery surprises
which writer Nicola Austin mentioned in
her Twitter analysis as well sharing the
flash is a compelling character-driven
flick with a real emotional core and
game-changing Stakes with heart and
humor of Plenty along with some shocks
and surprises there's so much to be
excited for Keaton steals a show with a
terrific performance a real Love Letter
to DC the majority of the first
reactions from Cinema con shower The
Flash with some extremely high praise
Fandango's Eric Davis thinks the flash
might actually be one of the very best
superhero movies out there he ranted on
Twitter about his love for the film
saying DC's The Flash is tremendous
forget DC it is without a doubt among
the best superhero films ever made an
old-timer inventive storytelling
Fantastic action sequences great cast so
many nerdy details I'm in tears at the
end everything you want from a superhero
film and more he also compared the movie
to the time travel classic Back to the
Future Eric Goldman a fandom also
tweeted good things about the movie
praising The Flash for its creative
decisions and sense of fun you're
strapped to your parachutes and where's
yours
of course not every one has had a chance
to watch the flashes entirely enamored
with her however DC fans should still be
pretty excited by the fact that even the
harsher critics are quick to admit that
the movie is a fun time Andrew J Salazar
of discussing film wrote his opinions on
Twitter saying the flash manages to
deliver glorious High Thrills Andy
muskete captures while many of us have
always dreamed for a cinematic flash
story but there's also plenty of just
bizarre decisions some Story related and
others technical not amazing but still
pretty good at times it's worth noting
that all this praise comes with a movie
still missing one big piece the hype
building post-credits scene Eric Goldman
explained on Twitter that he expects a
different closing when the film actually
goes to open in theaters all that said
the flashbacks plenty of punch in its
own right and the studio might still opt
to add a game-changing stinger or two as
the icing on the cake
[Music]
foreign